cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com for the New York Post Howard
Stern hits back at critics I am woke
mother effer and I love it
this is the perfect example I am so
grateful for Howard Stern because if
ever you want to explain to someone the
cult you need only show them Howard
Stern
he's uh he says I hear I hear that a lot
that I'm not good anymore because I'm
woke
by the way I kind of take that as a
compliment that I'm woke self-described
king of king of all media said on Monday
I'll tell you how I feel about it to me
the opposite of woke is being asleep
said Stern a staunch supporter of the
democratic party and if woke means I
can't get behind Trump which is what I
think it means or that I support people
who want to be transgender or and for
the vaccine dude to call me woke as you
uh call me call me woke as you effing
once turn added
let me break it down for you you don't
have to support Donald Trump
to oppose wokeness
you you don't have to be I mean and in
fact there are many people who oppose
wokeness who are trans who have gotten
the vaccine Howard Stern is the perfect
example of cult member
he's simply saying
I want money and I will suckle whatever
I need to suckle to get it a guy who now
look at this viral clips from uh 1999 I
think it was Columbine yeah where he was
saying I I'm not I can't even repeat
what he said yeah I'll try and keep it
as family friendly as possible Howard
Stern advocated for the Columbine
perpetrators
to have their way with their victims and
questioned why they wouldn't do it this
guy is as Despicable
as you can possibly imagine and he's
always been he's always been
so this is the funny thing right now
we're looking at everything he's saying
and being like what a spineless this is
his bit he always sides with evil
that's his thing well I mean but you
know he started off as being the the
Free Speech Warrior I mean I hate to
think that we're giving Howard Stern
what he wants right now because all he
wants is relevance he's not really
relevant anymore so this is his sort of
uh desperate grasp at being relevant
which you know really he's a drowning
man and now he's reaching up to pull
woke down with him which good riddance
uh because who wants to be associated
with someone like him I think he you
know he he actually explains what woke
is perfectly there he's like if you're
for the vaccine if you're for doing
whatever the powers tell you then that's
what I am I mean no dude you know if if
that's what if that's what he was to
have said but he's not I mean wokeness
is being a part of the cult you can have
reasonable disagreements on being for or
against certain gender ideological
ideology things or the vaccine there are
a lot of intelligent people who are not
woke who have real conversations about
this Howard Stern is basically just
saying don't know don't care whatever
they tell me to say I'll say please give
me more money yeah and I mean the
Columbine thing is what everybody's
talking about right now you can go on
YouTube you can watch old Howard Stern
shows from the 90s I'm not I'm not a
like prudish person at all but some of
the things they were saying back then
like you know make you make me go oh boy
I can't believe they said that the
Columbine thing yeah that's that's
really bad but in terms of like racist
and sex I mean he was pretty far out
there I mean if you you can find hours
of Howard Stern saying things that would
get him canceled and it's got a whole
movie about it private parts right right
if for some reason Howard Stern hit his
head and woke up a new person tomorrow
and he turned on this wokeness he would
be the next Target his show would be
canceled overnight yep and so he's
sitting in his in his studio and I'm
willing to bet someone came to him and
said hey man don't fly too close to the
Sun keep it keep it here you know here's
what we want and expect and he was like
you got a boss yeah just get and get
ahead of it too yup get ahead of it say
the right thing oh I mean the reason why
he's saying I'm woke I'm woke I'm woke I
swear I swear it's because all of these
clips are coming out which would get
anyone canceled well it's Uncle Uncle
Uncle right like he's getting his arm
twisted and he's throwing it out there
it's the Battle Cry I bet he cries at
night yeah I'm not kidding I'm I'm not
like I'm not trying to be like loser I'm
saying like I like you can't be a guy
who has your whole career based on
saying racial slurs and sexually
inappropriate things now be literally on
your knees beg talking begging like a
pathetic spineless little baby and feel
good about yourself he's he's been
pretty he was pretty open in private
parts that he's kind of a cowardly guy
like he did he came out and said the
same like he's like oh you know I'm kind
of scared of that
um and I mean that's that just kind of
shows here like he doesn't have the the
courage to stand up and and look at the
powers that be in in the face and say no
I'm not gonna just kiss the boot you
know
he says I want to be awake I want to
read legitimate news sources Stern also
alluded to claims made by Trump and his
supporters that President Biden's
victory was fraudulent here's how woke I
am I believe the election was not rigged
I am woke I think that's a compliment he
said it's like it's really weird that he
goes through a list of all of these
things saying please please I'm saying
the things I was told to say
I'm just imagining Howard Stern on his
knees crying as these like woke
20-something-year-old fat blue-haired
women are like say it or I'll get you
fired because we can email three people
and then he's just like please please
wow I just look man
I don't I could not understand
doing that we I talked about this before
when I was little
I'm like watching these historical
lessons or whatever in school or they
play cartoons
they tell stories about
someone would get captured and they
would say reject you or renounce your
faith otherwise we'll kill you and
they'd be like I will never do it and
then I'd be like why not just lie like
seriously just just say it and then now
I I wouldn't say I can I would
completely ever agree I do think there's
some value in just trying to escape
people who are attacking you and being
smart about it but now I get it to a
certain degree Howard Stern is the kind
of guy that would immediately fall to
his knees and offer to uh like if a guy
broke into his house
he'd just be like I will let you do
anything to my body I swear to God just
whatever you say man you can have you
can you can have anything including me
that's the kind of guy that he is
whereas like I'm sure most people listen
to this this show
uh me and many many people in this room
would not purport to be tough guys who
are gonna win a fight but would probably
try to protect our homes to whatever
degree we could whereas Howard Stern
would just drop to his knees and be like
tell me what to do and I'll do it
well it doesn't I mean has he left his
house yet I'm pretty sure he like went
into his basement when kovid first
started and like didn't leave until like
maybe a couple months ago it's turned
it's like oh yeah yeah oh no it's it's
like pathetic I mean literally a couple
months ago there was a clip going around
of him like getting mad at his wife for
like going out to do you know what I'm
talking about oh yeah I've seen that
again yeah yeah he he's he's a
hypochondriac I mean he is like still
living in the heart of covet um he he
eats crustless sandwiches because he
doesn't want he thinks there's bacteria
on the crust
could you imagine like take this article
and bring it back in time to to you know
the the 90s when Howard Stern is like
this shock Jack that everyone's talking
about like wow he's so crazy and then be
like nah that's who he really is it's so
embarrassing you know it's kind of crazy
because Legacy matters what are you
alive for you're alive to leave
something behind for your family for
your friends for your kids to have a
positive impact that makes Humanity
better
jeez well I mean this is Rage Against
the Machine forcing people to get
vaccinated before they go to their shows
rage on behalf of the machine yeah yeah
and I mean yeah you know it's it it is
it's it it all goes back to a spiritual
battle and that's what that's what I get
from all of what we've just seen Howard
Stern say is just this like deep-seated
really really like
really thorough spiritual cowardice
where he's gonna he's just like I just
believe whatever they tell me I believe
whatever they tell me I have no beliefs
higher than uh the humans around me who
order me around if Howard Stern was
sitting in a park eating a ham sandwich
and having a milkshake and a bunch of
trump supporters walked up to him and
they're like hey how are we gonna We
want to have a word with you he'll go I
I agree I love Trump
I've loved it the whole time I mean the
show is a show it's not real like you
guys know I've always been that guy he
will he will say anything I'm saying you
you could a guy in a Maga had could walk
up to him like Hey Howard nice to meet
you and he'll immediately be the kind of
guy who's like oh you know Trump's
actually really good I really like him
and the things in the show aren't real
just I'll say whatever I need to say
spineless cowardice seems like sad
sad but this is so many people it's not
just Howard's turn right there are so
many people right now and I'm sure the
people listening know people like this
that you know like I'll put it this way
everybody's got that friend more than
one maybe or family member who you know
has said something bad or done something
offensive
and all of a sudden now they're acting
hoity-toity acting like you know oh
everyone's got to fall in line why
they're scared it'll come for them
I was talking to some people from Vice
and I was uh telling about this I was
like dude back when we were working
there like the articles that they were
writing and stuff that the stuff that
they were that was getting all the
traffic and and hitting like they won't
do any of that stuff and they're like
well we can't do that anymore and I'm
like says who who says you can't write
the articles that people actually want
to read hey guess what Vice is bankrupt
congratulations everybody you you had a
choice to march in lockstep with losers
like Howard Stern and then lose all your
money and that's what you chose that's
really amazing I really do Wonder I'd
love to have a conversation with Shane
Smith haven't talked to the guy in a
decade I really wonder about how he let
them take his creation the scene under
the street the multi-billion dollar
Corporation grind it into a paste and
then crap it onto the floor
that's it I mean look when Vice was was
growing and expanding it was a big
threat to these these corporations they
all wanted a piece because they didn't
want to get left behind what do they do
instead infiltrate destroy and it's gone
yeah I don't know if they did that on
purpose or if it's just like an
inevitable consequence of uh being their
form of of woke or whatever you want to
call it well for advice it was because
they had a series of uh allegations
against so this is what I was I'm gonna
be very careful I was told this this is
true by uh people who are high up and
had been in the company for a very long
time that there were a series of
accusations made against uh prominent
employees some of this is widely
reported just Google search it you can
read it and the investors came in and
said the only way to deal with these
accusations and to not lose our deals
our contracts our sponsors and violent
morality Clauses is to become feminist
embrace the feminism become a champion
of the activism and push back on
misogyny and now you are protecting
yourself and they went you got it boss
and then just spiraled Into Obscurity
and weren't they and wasn't the main
investor George Soros or Soros
controlled uh organization uh no uh Vice
first got their big money from I think
it might have been Fox no it's not fair
they when they came I used to know it's
been so long I thought it was Disney and
so and that was way later uh it was uh
Disney and uh that was actually through
a e that Disney got involved I think it
was like uh a e was Hearst and is there
some kind of a Canadian Grant or
something like way back that's super
super way back super early days when
it's called voice of Montreal they came
to the US they got a little bit of money
I can't remember where it came from but
uh they had big investment from Rupert
Murdoch that was for that was first and
that's that's I miss Fox Corporation
right that was I think 70 million
dollars they had I believe that
investment from wpp which is basic like
people really need to look at what wpp
is and start researching that stuff
there's like one company that owns a
piece of all of these different media
properties and then later on they
brought in I think it was a e uh uh
which uh which basically brought that
money from from Disney and and I think
it's been a long time but I'll just keep
it simple I'll keep it simple
everybody knows Vice
and there was a point where I'm sure
most people watching they're in college
or they're getting out of college and
they're watching those Vice
documentaries and they were awesome they
were super cool yeah and then all of a
sudden somehow what happened I can give
you an example
when I started working for a vice one of
the one of the as part of my negotiation
was I flat out said to to the executives
I do live streaming and Social Media
stuff what I don't do is documentary
stuff I need that because in between big
breaking news what content is Tim Poole
releasing like what am I covering what
stories am I doing it's not always big
breaking stories so here's what we'll do
I will cover the big breaking news live
stream it to the millions of views and
then in the meantime we will produce
many documentaries around these stories
so put this we'll put it this way if I
go out and I cover say like Desi Park in
Turkey we can do two things we can film
a mini dock about it and we can live
stream it two birds with one stone and
then you guys are helping me where I
need help and they were like that's a
brilliant idea Tim welcome aboard you're
awesome and uh I was the first person
hired for Vice news and then what ends
up happening is one day one of The
Producers comes up to me and he's like
look man I know you really want to do
some of these documentaries and stuff
but uh this was specifically HBO there's
a lot more Nuance to it essentially the
original idea for Vice news was whatever
HBO wouldn't pick up they would run on a
different Channel and he said the thing
is HBO doesn't want white men we gotta
get more uh you know people of color and
women and I was like I'm mixed a mixed
race and they're like yeah that doesn't
matter you look white so and I'm like
and that's the game they play so here I
am I'm hired and then I got pissed and I
went to them and I said here's our
Arrangement here's what you promised and
they're like we know we know we know
they gave me more money and then
eventually I was like I'm out like if
you're gonna tell me that I can't host
things because of my race and literally
they did and I also say this too some
other producers like were very polite to
me and basically said without being mean
I wasn't that good at it and that's
totally fine you know I had one guy be
like you got to figure this stuff out
man okay and I'm like sure and another
guy was like the reality is we can edit
this stuff we can make it however it
needs to be made and we can direct you
hbr doesn't want white people and I was
like okay I was like all right there you
go an experiencing thing at Fusion so
let them let them let them all rot when
I see them failing when I see Vice
infusion wow how funny is this Tim cast
media is rapidly expanding we got the
coffee company is growing we're hiring
more people we're doing more show deals
we got a big announcement coming soon we
have this Big Show in Miami all of the
success that we've had watching behind
us as all of these people chose to burn
down what they were building because
they would rather bend the knee like
Howard Stern what a spineless pathetic
loser and that's what that's what
happens right when you take big
Investments when you welcome these
people on you give them the power to
destroy you or the power to control you
which and it's it is very it's so funny
because things like uh Tim Castor or
Infowars it's like when you actually
just rely on your audience and you give
your audience what you want what they
want and then they support you for it
you can actually expand and do amazing
things but as soon as the corporations
or the investors come in and start
ordering you around and making decisions
that are not you know focused on what
the audience wants it all starts to fall
apart you know hearing that story and in
in the context of Howard Stern his
time's up he's he's on a list he's the
low-lying fruit right now so we should
Circle back on this and whether it's six
months or a year I have a feeling Howard
Stern is going to be on the chopping
block this is why he's going so extreme
in the other direction yeah exactly he's
so you got a treadmill right and it's
speeding up and people are being flung
off the right side of it and Howard
Stern is running as fast as he can
because he's on that edge and he's got
to just try an inch as much again it's
going to be really difficult for him but
I mean I got I gotta be honest he would
be better off if he just stayed himself
yeah if he totally just went the shut up
you losers and just stayed himself he'd
be doing way better he doesn't have to
support Trump he doesn't have to hate
vaccines he just needs to stop being a
whiny little loser who's like just
bending the knee and doing whatever he's
told but whatever man hey he can do he
can do whatever he wants uh he has I
wonder if he has any respect from anyone
I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll add this
he's saying whatever Boomers he thinks
whatever he thinks Boomers want to hear
that's it
that's where he's at
he doesn't care what we think I'm half
his age how old is a guy 70 or something
he didn't care pretty old yeah yeah so
he's he's not trying to impress me he's
trying to impress other Boomers and
that's that that's the reality of how
Generations work like we don't do this
show specifically targeting 19 year olds
we don't do like that like some
companies do that weird stuff where they
try and Pander you know like hello
fellow kids you know like we we just be
ourselves that's what we do we be
ourselves and then what happens is the
attitudes the world view the things we
like resonate with people close to our
age that's exactly what he's doing he's
69 years old look at that he's ready to
run for Congress thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time